the little voice in your head is called
the insecurity devil the insecurity
devil on your shoulder is saying to you
don't do this because when you fail the
girl you like your brother your mom your
teacher like someone's going to think
you suck and you believe them and that's
the problem when I started public
speaking and losing out on speaking gigs
left and right cuz I cursed I knew that
I was going to double down on what got
me there which was I'm not going to
overv Value other people's opinions I'm
going to value my opinion about myself
if people really got into a place of
just doing things that they want to do
and not worrying about what people
thought about it everybody would take
risks in their 20s the reason people are
scared of the world is they actually
think getting fired or having their
startup fail or them not being able to
be an influencer cuz nobody gave a
is a bad thing when I think it's a great
thing this all comes down to confidence
and insecurity the reason you won't do
something is you are too insecure to do
it